e aí
g1
o efeito borboleta
e quando viu o tema do tédio comecei a
pensar que que isso tem a ver com a
minha vida
e isso me fez viajar para um
autoconhecimento
e nessa viagem que eu comecei a fazer me
deparei com a seguinte situação eu
estava apresentando um trabalho era o
primeiro trabalho da empresa que eu
fundei a 7 anos atrás dentro de uma
grande multinacional com todo board
internacional e o presidente me
perguntou assim dilma como é que você
veio parar aqui e eu respondi já haviam
peguei o avião em são paulo vem para o
rio de janeiro e aqui estou eu e ele
começou a rir assim como vocês fizeram
agora e eu quase ali como indignada tá
rindo do que ele falou não foi bem isso
que eu perguntei eu queria saber como
você uma mulher negra em todos os danos
aonde foi expirou de várias empresas no
brasil não encontrei nenhuma como você
aqui em frente a um bordo internacional
apresentando um trabalho
olá
olá neste momento eu olhei para dentro
de mim e me revisitei de novo com efeito
borboleta de como é que foi que eu
cheguei até aqui eu descobri que na
minha vida eu percorri vários picos e
isso daria uma grande teoria uma teoria
dos vários picos alguns foram grandes
outros menores algum passaram
rapidamente outro parece que ainda não
passaram mas todos tiveram seu tempo
perto coerente correto
é mas foi na imprensa da minha família
que eu encontrei forças para chegar aqui
foi nessa inspiração este é o meu pai
meu pai foi um grande jogador de
basquete e foi no esporte que mudou o
nosso olhar o poder olhar um pouco mais
à frente
e esta é a minha família ter mulher do
lado de dois irmãos é mais ou menos sem
saber quem sou eu
e numa família aonde tudo que te fala é
esporte e quando a pessoa não tem
aptidão com bola qual é o assunto que
você fala nenhum vocês a crescem mulher
sem ter o que falar essa do meio dele
tadinho sou eu o de cor-de-rosa é meu
irmão mais velho projeta isso a 20
tantos anos atrás onde usar cor-de-rosa
não era tão comum mas a minha mãe era
uma grande gestora financeira tudo
aquilo que recebia era usado para os
três filhos não importando a cor que
fosse
é bom como meus irmãos que eram muito
bons com bola e eu não eles ganharam
bolsas de estudo e isso fez uma grande
transformação na minha família eu fui
para dança aliás primeiro eu fui para a
ginástica olímpica mas precisarão me
explicar e ginástica olímpica não era
karatê
oi e eu tive que aprender então me
colocaram no balé mas lá eu me encontrei
foi lá no balé que eu descobri de fato
quem eu era
bom e foi pela primeira vez o tentando
que eu fiz aqui desse lado o personagem
principal do espetáculo foi aí que eu
descobri que eu podia chegar um passo
mais para frente que eu podia chegar
além daquela caixinha que tinha me
colocado quando eu nasci mas que também
eu poderia escolher aonde eu poderia
chegar
é mas foi através de educação esse ouro
do conhecimento que a gente em casa
descobriu que a gente tinha uma vida
muito melhor foi quando eu decidi que eu
não ia mais ser caixa de supermercado
quando pequena eu queria acertar está
supermercado que aonde eu vi a mulheres
negras trabalharem sem ser na casa de
outras pessoas e a educação poderia me
dar uma chance eu poderia ser inclusive
gerente dos caixas de supermercado
zattere algo muito maior do que aquilo
que eu havia sonhado como pequena mas a
educação me levou a outros lugares com
educação comecei a praticar nós
estudávamos num colégio estadual colégio
estadual josé cândido de souza para os
íntimos candinho e eu fui para um
colégio particular chamado colégio anglo
lá
o que deu início ao sistema anglo de
ensino então um colégio muito mais forte
e dentro dessa minha experiência de
educação no primeiro dia de aula eu
aprendi três coisas que eu quero
compartilhar com vocês a primeira coisa
que eu aprendi é que nós éramos negros
e como assim você não sabia sim eu sabia
mas no colégio que eu estudava eu tinha
outros iguais então não fazia a
diferença quando nós mudamos preci
colégio de 2.500 alunos onde só haviam
três negros você sim é muito diferente
e a segunda coisa que eu aprendi é que
nós éramos pobre perdão meu pai nunca
gostou dessa palavra e quando ele foi
nos buscar nesse primeiro dia de aula
que eu perguntei papai nós somos pobres
ele falou quem disse isso as amiguinhas
da escola não é verdade e ele disse o
seguinte aprenda uma coisa pobre é quem
é pobre de espírito vocês são pessoas
simples e isso fez muita diferença
é mas tem uma terceira coisa que eu
aprendi eu aprendi que a disneylândia
existia
é verdade aonde eu estudava passava a
tarde o clube do mickey na televisão e
aí mostrava o mickey o castelo da
cinderela as pessoas mas eu não fazia
bem aonde ficava essa disneylândia e se
de fato ela existia mas quando eu mudei
de colégio as meninas vinham com uma
fotografia chegando das férias abraçada
com quem o mickey e aí eu coloquei na
minha cabeça que dieta disneyland
existia esse elas conseguiram chegar até
lá era lá que eu queria chegar um dia
bom então para isso eu descobri que eu
precisava estudar estudar muito porque
isso seria ter sorte a definição de
esporte para o meu pai era a seguinte
você trabalha cinco vezes mais que os
outros você estuda a três vezes mais que
os outros e aí sim você pode dizer que
você terá uma mulher de muita sorte não
é verdade essa definição de parte bom me
apliquei nos estudos não sei porque teu
tá aí ounap gostando de estudar ou
porque eu descobri que de fato era o
ouro me formei aos 17 anos me casei aos
19 anos tudo para dar errado
bom e comecei a trabalhar com 13 anos
aos 13 anos de idade ajudando as
bailarinas pequenininhas da escola aonde
eu fazia aula também era uma forma de
pagar as mensalidades do mês
e o que aconteceu é que o estudo me
levou a muitos lugares o sonho do meu
pai era o seguinte filhos eu só quero
que vocês pisem numa universidade como
assim pisar não é sim eu quero que vocês
entrem numa universidade da família do
meu pai nós somos a primeira geração que
pisou numa universidade eu sou esta
geração
oi e aí precisava se formar não porque
sabe o que você teria uma coisa que meu
pai não teve superior incompleto para
poder marcar em qualquer ficha
bom e foi assim
eu fui para faculdade me formei em
odontologia sou especialista em
periodontia e não exerço essa profissão
e eu pensava conhecer o mundo do de
vento e ali eu me entreguei então tudo
que eu fiz foi pagando através dos
eventos que eu fazia
e depois de passar por grandes empresas
de eventos o que aconteceu na minha vida
foi que eu resolvi empreender e
empreender não é a coisa mais a todo
mundo não é a mais difícil não é mas não
é a mais fácil do mundo há 7 anos atrás
resolvi abrir a outra praia a minha
empresa e esse processo foi um processo
muito intenso porque quando eu resolvi
empreender eu me tornei esse ou e
fundadora da minha empresa e quantas
mulheres negras eu via para poder seguir
para poder me inspirar
e nenhuma
a pouca uma
a dua
oi e aí eu falei tem coisa errada isso
me fez novamente olhar para dentro e
dizer eu preciso de um propósito na vida
que me falta mudar esta realidade que me
dê a chance de mudar essa realidade e
foi aí que eu comecei a compartilhar a
minha história e isso aconteceu depois
que eu fundei a minha empresa a outra
praia uma empresa de live marketing que
faz na verdade evento
o e de compartilhar em camping canto
essa história para dizer para outras
mulheres negras que sim é possível a
gente chegar foi que eu fui escolhida
para um projeto mundial do google
chamado o homem no rio para ser
palestrante deste projeto esta sou eu em
natal com mais de duas mil e quinhentas
mulheres
e foi daí que eu descobri que dentro de
todos aqueles picos da minha vida picos
de altos de baixo com dinheiro tenho
dinheiro mas sim com muita dignidade e
com muita transparência e coerência
naquilo que eu queria que eu descobri
que eu só tinha chegado aonde eu cheguei
aonde estou longe porque eu nunca
desisti
e eu imprimi uma camiseta que diz assim
desistir jamais e é isso o que eu
procuro passar e compartilhar na minha
vida dia a dia com todas as mulheres que
eu falo
e em toda minha vida eu juro para você
eu nunca imaginei que hoje eu tivesse
aqui em minas gerais na cidade de lavras
fazendo um pedex
eu nunca nos meus maiores sonhos nos
meus sonhos mais ousados eu achei que eu
fosse papai de chegar aqui
é mas eu cheguei
a porém eu sei que ir sozinha
bom e é isso que hoje não faz sentido na
minha vida e que vida foi essa que picos
foram esses eu comecei como bailarina
quando eu comecei fazer evento eu
comecei com assistente do assistente de
palco eu fui assistente de direção de
palco até chegar assistente de direção
artística eu fui diretora artística de
eventos e pedida aos meus 22 anos eu fui
fazer a faculdade porque eu não tinha
dinheiro para fazer aos 22 anos e já
casada e depois depois dentro da área de
eventos eu passei pela área de
planejamento pela área de atendimento
e até chegar numa grande empresa a
diretora de produção de eventos
o cargo que também confesso nunca
imaginei que eu pudesse alcançar
e mais a vida me levou até ali foram
esses vários ciclos e daí parte por
empreendedorismo
e eu aprendi na minha vida que não
importa da onde eu vinha mas sim importa
aonde eu ia chegar e é nisso que eu
acredito que todos esse ciclo foram de
muito amor que todos esses ciclos da
onde eu vim para onde eu cheguei eles
construíram esta pessoa que está aqui
compartilhando tudo o que aconteceu na
sua vida agora e hoje com vocês
e eu disse que eu fui bailarina que hoje
eu sou e o da minha empresa que hoje é a
minha empresa já participou e já
apareceu no pequenas empresas grandes
negócios e sptv falando de
empreendedorismo ou seja ela conseguiu
alguma relevância desse mercado não
importa da onde eu vim importa ainda
onde eu quero chegar e para mostrar para
vocês que de fato eu comecei dançando eu
vou mostrar aqui um pedacinho pode ser
e aí
o que você quiser tá botando aqui na
árvore cai fora pezinho de barros das
patativas passarinho passarinho na
internet e
e aí
e não importa da onde a gente vem só
importa aonde a gente quer chegar e sem
amor a gente de fato não chega a lugar
nenhuma muito obrigada a